[Musica]
[Applauso]
quante emozioni sepolte ognuno di noi
porta dentro di sé sa quante verità
siamo costretti a reprimere per paura di
non essere ascoltati o di non essere
capiti spesso tendiamo a reprimere i
nostri bisogni le nostre paure le nostre
ansie pur di non essere giudicati
oppure di non dare fastidio
in realtà così facendo non risolviamo
nulla anzi reprimere una necessità
emotiva di qualunque natura essa sia
rischia di trasformarla in qualcosa di
molto più grande che ci logora
dall'interno o che comunque si lascia
una fastidiosa sensazione di incompiuto
e inutile negarlo è successo a tutti e
di conseguenza è successo anche a me e
adesso vi racconterò una di queste
esperienze non molto tempo fa mi sono
ritrovata in una relazione estremamente
tossica estremamente in cui non veniva
neanche lontanamente trattata come avrei
dovuto
e come d'altronde ognuno di noi merita
eppure quale era l'unica sensazione che
io mi permettevo di provare l'ansia
l'ansia di non essere abbastanza l'ansia
di essere abbandonata dall altra persona
in realtà se mi fossi concessa di
ascoltarmi meglio e di andare un po più
a fondo mi sarei resa conto che dietro a
quell ansia in realtà si nascondeva
soltanto rabbia che io reprime vaud e
non ascoltavo lei provava a parlarmi lei
provava a comunicare con me provava a
dirmi che io ero abbastanza che non
merito di essere trattata in questo modo
e soprattutto che lui stava calpestando
il mio io ma io continuavo ad ignorarla
continua a fingere di essere un'altra
persona per paura che in un qualche modo
se mi fosse mostra mi fossi mostrata per
quello che ero non sarei andata bene
quindi reprime vo i miei bisogni e mi
lasciavo trascinare soltanto dalla paura
però le nostre emozioni sono lì per
guidarci il nostro istinto è lì per
comunicare con noi
infatti mi ricordo che quando finalmente
sono riuscita a razionalizzare questa
emozione a guardare in faccia questa
paura e quest'ansia pronta alla sfida mi
attorno ha in mente una frase di young
che avevo letto qualche tempo prima da
qualche parte fino ad allora non avevo
realmente compreso la forza del suo
significato ma in quel momento era
chiara la sua potenza
ciò che neghi si sottomette ciò che
accetti ti trasforma infatti io mi sono
trasformato
il vero scatto l'ho fatto quando
finalmente ho accettato la verità da cui
io tanto scappavo in realtà io avevo
paura di rimanere da sola il pur di non
rimanerci mi accontentavo di persone non
adatti a me ma che soprattutto non mi
rispettavano e molto spesso mi
calpestavano e soltanto quando
finalmente ho deciso di ascoltare
realmente le mie emozioni ho capito che
ciò di cui avevo bisogno era proprio
quello da cui scappavo io avevo bisogno
di rimanere da sola era sano in quel
momento per me rimanere sola così
finalmente ci sono riuscito e ho capito
che non era neanche così tanto
spaventoso come potevo immaginare a
riguardo ha scritto una breve canzone su
questa su questa rinascita
quante volte non riesco a stare
[Musica]
perché
[Applauso]
affrontare le nostre paure le nostre
ansie o comunque qualunque mozione che
ci logora dall'interno significa tirarla
fuori non importa come in realtà
l'importante è che non resti chiusa lì
dentro bisogna si può parlare di segnare
urlare non importa bisogna però trovare
il coraggio di buttarla fuori la mia
arma contro questo fatidico mostro era
ed è tuttora il canto cantare e scrivere
canzoni in un qualche modo riesce a
portare fuori la mia verità è come se
tramite la mia voce io riuscissi ad
eliminare quella fitta nebbia che non mi
permetteva di guardare al di là del mio
naso e a vedere le cose così come sono
quando canto io mi sento libera mi sento
forte mi sento me stessa tuttavia ad un
certo punto mi sono resa conto che
questo non mi bastava io avevo bisogno
di
raccontare la mia esperienza di
raggiungere altri avevo bisogno di
condividere quello che avevo vissuto con
altre persone così a marzo della prima
quarantena sono riuscita a scrivere
questa canzone in cui parlavo di quanto
fossi stufa dei giudizi esterni e delle
pretese esterne anche se inizialmente
non ho avuto il coraggio di farla
sentire a nessuno né di pubblicarla
niente l'ho ottenuta per me perché
perché io avevo paura che i diretti
interessati in un qualche modo potessero
sentirsi sentirsi chiamati in causa a un
certo punto sono rinsavite ho detto io
sono il personaggio di questo atto
questa è la mia storia questa è la mia
esperienza queste sono le mie emozioni e
io sono stufa di avere paura ho bisogno
di raccontarle era diventata quasi una
missione volevo raggiungere più persone
possibili le stesse persone che in un
qualche modo potevano vivere qualcosa
potevano aver vissuto qualcosa di simile
al mio la necessità di aiutarle così ad
aprile di quest'anno
così per caso fondamentalmente ho
pubblicato un breve spezzone di questa
canzone su tik tok
inaspettatamente la canzone è diventata
virale ma la cosa più bella
fondamentalmente è stato vedere quante
persone si rispecchiavano in quello che
dicevo e soprattutto mi ringraziassero
per essere riuscita in un qualche modo a
dare voce alle emozioni che molto spesso
è difficile tirare fuori questo è stato
è stato bellissimo e soprattutto mi sono
sentita meno sola meno sola perché
vedere quanti mi capissero mi ha fatto
sentire appunto compresa e si sa che
insieme sia più forti
alla fine pensate un po come possano
andare le cose mi ha contattato un
produttore di modena marco cavaliere
insieme abbiamo concluso questa canzone
e l'abbiamo pubblicata su tutte le
piattaforme musicali ed ecco se ti va
[Musica]
no ma il piercing non mi piace io lo
toglierei è questo quello che mi dicono
ogni volta che si fanno i cazzi miei
e non è nemmeno questo il problema è che
è solo l'inizio di una carrellata di
pretese che poi diventano un supplizio
una volta un mix mi disse di matrice
niente male come se io da sola al mare
non ci riuscissi proprio andare come se
non avessi gambe una macchina una vita
ed una voce
è questo quello che devi fare per sordi
stesso fa ciò che vuoi senza può pensare
devi farlo senza chiedere il permesso
fare quello che
è questo quello che
il peso nord
cioè ciò che vuoi senza poi pensare
adesso
ieri farlo senza chiedere permesso
cambia come bene vito quando soffierà
affettiva
cambia come se nessuno guarda cassetti
non capisco poi il bisogno di contestare
ogni cosa come quando mi hanno detto non
ti può avvertire di rosa questa vostra
abitazione su un controllo della gente
forse non vi è chiaro ma non porta
proprio niente
definire ciò che sono per quello che
indosso ma il modo in cui la zona che se
questo
[Musica]
cambio strada
e questo quello che devi fare per
salvarti stesso fa ciò che vuoi senza
pensare al resto devi farlo senza
chiedere il permesso fare quello che è
questo quello che devi fare per salvarti
stesso fa ciò che vuoi senza pensare al
resto
di fare senza chiedere
pescara
cambia come il vento quando sotto grazie
tv
cambia come se nessuno guarderà sentina
e questo
mai tutto mi rimbalza a
tempo per pensare
le ba e la scala
[Musica]
è questo quello che devi fare per
salvarti stesso pezzo che poi senza poi
pensare al resto deve farlo senza
chiedere il permesso e fuori quello che
[Applauso]
perciò se il canto era ciò che mi
permetteva di tirare fuori le mie
emozioni tik tok era il mezzo con cui
finalizzava questo percorso arrivando
appunto alla condivisione
d'artista questo format potrebbe
risultare limitante perché come molti di
voi sapranno è fatto da pochi secondi di
video però dall'altra parte può comunque
essere utili utilizzato come uno spunto
per reinventarsi per trovare nuove forme
artistiche e creative io ho capito la
forza di questo format nel momento in
cui io ho pubblicato appunto la piccola
parte di questa canzone qui ed è
diventata virale
lì ho capito quanto questa combinazione
di parte parlata e parte cantata in un
qualche modo arrivasse prima era come se
le persone avessero molta più voglia di
ascoltarmi se lo facevo tramite nella
musica tramite una canzone così l'ho
iniziato ad utilizzare per esprimere le
mie emozioni miei sentimenti le mie
verità a chiunque avesse voglia di
ascoltarle in realtà all'interno delle
mie canzoni non parlo soltanto delle mie
emozioni ma parlo anche dei miei
pensieri infatti un tema di cui molto
spesso parlo è proprio la lotta contro
l'omofobia la lotta contro il razzismo
la lotta contro ogni tipo di
discriminazione
per me è molto importante parlare di
queste cose perché non solo definiscono
in un qualche modo chi sono e chi voglio
essere ma segnano la mia vita
secondo me è essenziale esporsi su temi
del genere anche perché in qualche modo
in qualche modo voglio arrivare a
sensibilizzare ea trasmettere un
messaggio positivo alle nuove
generazioni ai miei coetanei che usano
titò che sono reattivi a questi
contenuti brevi fondamentalmente è
quindi una volta mi trovavo da un
osteopata e questo questa strofa ha
iniziato a fare questo discorso in cui
rivendicava in un qualche modo la
superiorità italiana prendendo come
esempio i vari poeti e grandi della
letteratura italiana però per sminuire
altre culture e quindi a me è venuto
spontaneo fare un ragionamento che poi
ho inserito in quest'altra breve canzone
tempo fa un ignorante
[Musica]
soprattutto
solamente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non teniamoci dentro ciò che proviamo
non lasciamoci tentare dalla chiusura
non dobbiamo avere paura di parlare e di
dire quello che pensiamo non dobbiamo
credere che quello che proviamo sia
stupido irrilevante che siamo gli unici
approvarlo oppure che non interessi a
nessuno
dobbiamo trovare il coraggio di
comunicare che sia parlando urlando
cantando e disegnando non importa ma
soprattutto dobbiamo condividere che sia
tramite tik tok come nel mio caso o
tramite qualunque altro mezzo non
importa condividiamo parliamo discutiamo
argomentiamo così sarà più facile vedere
le cose così come sono libere dalla le
libere dalla nebbia distinte eppure
grazie
[Applauso]